hi my name is mama depandi go hi I'm 14
I love include Mississippi I'm in eighth
grade and i also got more of me in
junior high as also include mississippi
this is my third year pissing in the
National Geographic me this is a second
time going to the national stage the
first time of wows in sixth grade those
are totally the experience for me and
this is my second time going to
Nationals and I'm very proud for the
Nationals this year and Cleveland their
supply to do you can hang out with
friends which is one thing I like doing
but you can go to the park there's a
swing set for the little kids into trail
there's also the tennis attendance
quarter there's also the day at DSC
which is Delta State University it's
where my mom works they have a
tremendous library and because i'm garna
LeClair has been a lot of time over
there to the time for me for being green
to most people will actually it means
that um honey back which I gotta believe
in you can actually expand a lot with
being green you guys should make plenty
of money you can even cut out a lot of
in efficiencies that you normally have
of angering or replacing replacing green
subset of using oil or petroleum and
natural gas hospitals if I to trade
places in any way der it would be missin
Churchill learn to hide the Blitz an old
whore tia how we have Hebrides Burton
for the battled and um he waits Britain
and the British Empire all between the
victory against Nazi Germany it takes
incredible out of courage and daring to
get it to continue in before in to
achieve victory find a free ticket I
would probably go to Germany probably
some old war routine monuments same in
Japan probably seeing it at her own
atomic bomb went off cars popular again
you don't have to smush bunch stuff into
your brain as long just visualize the
maps you know if you want to cram all
these books into your head and all that
if you just visualize the maps danger
far easier that's the best study tip for
me I was in charge us for the day I find
a replacement to help us write any of
you needs instead of using oil I
probably use solar panels or wind energy
oh and did you know this National
Geographic that futon is a land of the
thunder dragon
you